u Uè Buonasera a tutti Ma che è sto
mortorio Meno male che è arrivata la
regina della festa pronti per il karaoke
e tuo mor
sorprende In che senso tocca te Non sai
manco cantare io ho fatto 237 concerti
in giro per tutta l'Italia nel 2003
oppure vinto un concorso di danze
caraibiche l'artista di questa famiglia
sono io e Adesso vatti a sedere va amore
amore amore amore mia finalmente ti sei
fidanzata Manuele quello che abita alla
casa allang è sempre stato innamorato di
me a me però non è mai piaciuto troppo
os Ah ti ha detto che non è vero quando
la volpe non arriva all'uva Mi stai
dando della prepotente a me Partendo dal
presupposto che io non mi sbaglio mai
non è un mio problema se la sicurezza è
me stessa mette a disagio le persone
Adesso basta discussione dove sta
l'alcool penso
sempre